it's your accent that your this it's
like it's the it's cuz your mom told you
you weren't good enough but there's so
many things I chew I what's your
alternative like like I just think that
people are scared to fail in front of
other people my friends I'm telling you
something right now I'm desperately
excited to fail in front of you because
I don't really give a [ __ ] what you
think and B I'm going to learn from it
and see battle scars are attractive
about 130 30 people all the tech
industry about 3/4 of them are marketers
VP's a marketing GMOs I'm like what kind
of companies mostly like startup to
mid-sized tech companies ok b2b or b2c
being represent anything excited I'm
excited too you're welcome music-wise
yeah oh anything maybe uh maybe some
bone thugs-n-harmony not familiar but
I'll find it anything you do is find
Beebe's is great thank you so much
oh yeah why don't we do I want to know
but maybe you shouldn't be here while
I'm eating well take it again
stick it again so I appreciate you
coming thank you for having there in
your knowledge yeah I thank you
important in our team you know I
appreciate
yeah I mean you know it's funny I'm
passionate about the b2b space I think a
lot of people think social media is for
- b2c space right so I'm excited about
who's in the audience tonight you should
be good yeah thanks yeah no worries
tonight you know so funny I used to
always make fun of sports announcers who
would be calling a day game and they
would say tonight the Knicks play the
Bulls I'm like it's 1:30 afternoon and
now it's freakin 9:30 and I'm like the
great audience tonight it's so weird how
your brain does that sorry baby Arielle
and Ari are gonna be great because I
really think musically is about the
stick its landing and now just you know
like it'd be awesome to look back in
early episodes of like Twitter stars or
vine stars if I our YouTube stars yeah
before it was I mean I knew Phil
DeFranco when he had four followers on
YouTube you know even Casey when he was
first on me didn't hat blow up yet as
you wear your being shirt hey Casey
great news I found I found a fan look at
this bean shirt The Rock's rockin D bean
okay we can do it tomorrow then yeah we
can do it tomorrow okay I gotta go I
think see ya
thank you thank you
you found bone thugs-n-harmony I'm
impressed
Facebook running ads against 60 year
olds saying are your parents in need of
the our services here's one thing that I
know about 60 year olds on Facebook this
is how a 22 year old goes through their
feed on Facebook here's how a 60 year
old goes to their feed that's what I'm
interested in
attention attention imagine walk into
your business right now me like I got or
if it's your business I got an idea
we're gonna become a media company we're
gonna hire an editor-in-chief for
150,000 a year we're gonna hire some
staff writers a video person and we're
gonna launch a site called small
business daily I mean like people to be
like what the [ __ ] the matter with you
in the same way they would have if you
said social media is gonna be a big
thing and you can sell stuff there or
that or like hi
we represent a bunch of influencers
right and we do a lot of stuff with them
I have 14 year old girls I'm musically
making 500 thousand dollars a year
lip-synching right so that's not
something businesses believed thirty six
months ago my whole life my whole life
has been on anticipating where the
world's going 20 and by the way back to
that Jenna's question in the back that
started off with the Pokemon 24 months
from now because I can hold up my
business for 24 months to get there not
six years
I'm not developing VR wine technology
right now because I don't think it's 24
months but media is now and definitely
24 months it's just not how people think
so I'm empathetic of like getting
laughed out of the room guys that really
appreciate your time thank you
thank you guys thank you thank your
brother Springfield Oh No kidding
hi I live in the city now but I almost
opened a store in Aberdeen which is very
close to yeah I'm Tricia Bagley oh thank
you for sure thank you
I got to hear about the first 40 minutes
thank you
I did thank you oh of course they pulled
I'm like going thank you thank you
Phil we're healthcare protocol for
marketing so I mean you know so who's
the target
physicians Foster's facilities like I'm
what are you trying to sell them York
well it's our service you know we do a
lot of our management for them yep but
then now we're also growing at you I see
okay like all the products - like with
networking and all that stuff and so so
think about it backwards think about
everything in articles why physicians
why hospitals need to start caring about
privacy and then write that article why
independent physicians need to
understand snapchat and write that
article that's how I reverse engineer
once you start with what you think they
should be thinking about like whatever
your IT you're selling there's a why
mm-hmm there's a why you think they
should have it right you know like
people of lions don't be the doctor that
loses your patients data yeah article
then that article or video is deployed
against physicians on LinkedIn against
physicians on Facebook understand yes I
see what I'm afraid of with with
Facebook is because the physicians yes
who says well you that's your focus
group of five or 50 is too small you
don't think dr. John's on [ __ ]
Facebook
all my positions are on Facebook I have
three they're all there I see their
[ __ ] pictures they're there as John
not as Doctor John doesn't mean John
doesn't see the video and if John sees
why physicians to start worrying about
data John might read that when he's
having his coffee on Tuesday morning
that's the problem people make decisions
on their focus group musically is gonna
be big people sameen email well my 14
year old daughter says it's not cool
anymore
Mazel Tov but your 14 year old
daughter's not [ __ ] every
fourteen-year-old in America so the data
shows that plenty of doctors are on
Facebook probably most of them thank you
got it
thanks dude take care brother
stay well yes okay I'm sorry
a lot of times one of the things I've
always historically have done that was
really good at in 2011 12 13 when I was
a little bit less busy than harder now
but I found a little pocket cause a call
just got canceled is engaged with the
content produced from the keynote that I
give you know it you know it's a
never-ending cycle of engagement context
brand building relationship building and
so you give a talk people tweet about it
really at the height of Twitter when
people were live tweeting it was
incredible sometimes a lot of times when
I was in Europe or far away from the
airport of where I gave a talk that
whole hour two hours I would just
engaged with everybody that made pro/con
you know night you know luckily my
speaking 95 percent positive 3 percent
indecisive 2% mad that I cursed you know
point zero percent one point zero five
percent of people like adamantly
disagreeing and so you would engage pro
con and different a lot of thanks a lot
of Winkies a lot of now with the way
Twitter works just even giving a heart
makes people know that you saw it gives
them a it's kind of like you know twenty
I used to reply now the hearts even
quick are the like the heart of whatever
you want to call it on Twitter I think
people underestimate the link the head
nod actually this is very weird somebody
said the second you know somebody just
tweeted
if you want to do it for Batum we get it
right that moment when you walk into the
room and you and Gary be head give each
other a head nod you know it's gonna be
a good day or something like that that
um that that's what a heart is you know
like this guy you know just mentioning
you know seriously genuine stuff from
fan chapter two boom little heart there
you know from a guy who knows you know
boom a little heart there now Tom knows
that like I saw it I appreciate it
don't underestimate a wink like
acknowledging another human being in a
positive way takes all forms this it
could be a four-hour dinner or it could
be a quick little you know I love
looking at people when I walk I were
strangers my whole life in the airport I
do it a ton I'll just look at him and be
like like like powerful you know you
know driving positivity acknowledgement
interacting with other humans doing the
right thing by each other is mostly
under estimating so doing the virtual
version of that book if you must ask
Kurian I feel like I feel like I'm like
a little like startup toy for you I feel
like you're just like yeah sometimes I'm
just like shut your face
don't bother me ever again
to let you like to the points everyday
I'm really well how are you guys gonna
win with or without that and we still
got a really long way to go before you
hear what I'm saying on the radio so
let's teach the children and build a
nation a whole lot better than the one
we're facing in some chumps I feel like
the voltage integration god I'm
connecting my Instagram to my cell
number no can't remove your phone number
yep next up toddler tell them I can't
call choice because uh that was
interesting yeah I don't get a lot of
calls from numbers I don't know some of
this
just actually you know I don't think you
realize your phone number is on your
Instagram but my name is Elizabeth
Taylor and I have a lease around here
and we are you biggest fan and we met
you at Ikon 2016 and you're [ __ ]
amazing yep
so yeah my phone was public on Instagram
for 39 seconds should I call back
oh this is Alyssa and Allie this is
super happening my phone I connected I
was connecting my Instagram to a
business profile and for like 39 seconds
my phone number was there and your guys
hustle got it so I wanted to call you
back and give you love and apps for your
hustle I love it I love it all right I
have to go make a call but I wanted to
say what's up okay bye bye
I may not need to shower showers tend to
be like anything before 9:00
you know like 8 a.m. 7 a.m. 6 a.m.
because I'm waking up so then I sleep
like there I should have a good night's
sleep and leave at 6
I should it'll be kind of in between I
mean I still would want a shower so take
a look hey Jason well I'm about to make
this [ __ ] video for you while I sit
in this hotel room so real quick as I'm
leading through the notes is when when
you guys in the notes it says what's in
it for the distributors and the whole
and the salespeople obviously know them
very well
is this why why they should be excited
that is spending money and doing
marketing in these channels so that yep
all right brother
yep how you doing no worries I'm sad I
couldn't make it because obviously
that's like a perfect venue for me
what's up gang this is Gary Vaynerchuk
CEO of vaynermedia because there's way
too many 20 year olds heck there's way
too many 40 50 and 60 year olds that
think they have to make a million a year
to be successful cool 24 months ago me
and this good-looking character named D
Rock ran into a room at vaynermedia and
what's up Gary VIP it's me
gary vee in new york city my hometown
can't wait to bring the Thunder but are
you ready hey my first lively finally
Jesus I finally got in big fan of all
you guys back hope you guys are enjoying
my musically stuff huge fan of yours to
kevro this looks a lot like Facebook
live can I start it - well I can do my
own heart I can add somebody I can share
on Twitter got it that is pretty cool
post there
very cool so up age go-go 12 Maddie
good stuff young hustlers we go 30 legit
great number 12 K burns love at 50 114
33:29 love it love love love 27 35 love
10 boy athlete is a 10 year old hustler
that's what I'm talking about baby
yes boy athlete love it 13 monkey money
monkey money baby 13 you hot like I
would have been so hardcore as a 13 year
old hustler yeah could you imagine
looking back in like 13 14 15 year old
business videos love it alright little
fun with lively much loves everybody go
Jets way and I mean way too many of you
way too many of you are doing [ __ ] you
hate once in a blue moon maybe several
times in your career you'll embark on an
adventure where even from the minute you
start it you know that it's gonna be
something big but it depends on where
your head's at right now August it's
good right
yeah I think I got something guys I'm
super pumped up right now I think I just
made a big time video d-roc I think I
got something it's called August I think
there's some food coming right hey man
this is Ivan Ivan how are you good man
the whole memories smart really really
laugh it up just right by the button
seems like you guys have inaccurate
thumbs so this dude and this dude are
mad about the the little button below
sounds like inaccurate thumbs to me I've
never hit it I didn't even know what the
hell you guys were talking about they
know that but I don't know you design it
yeah yeah we happens like I have to take
I like rock back shirt all the time
everybody sends me messages I know how
are you I read Tyree real pleasure
security guy Keith they said before he
leaves tonight that's all I want is a
picture of that I love it
very first question is this what
applause it is Mayor Don Roose what
don't sleep on my skills West [ __ ] I'm
so pumped I got that right what
go ahead oh I have no idea whom the
guide Nolan Ryan shared his rookie card
with oh holy [ __ ] I hate this [ __ ]
guy
90 FLIR this guy's guys you all know me
this is the only thing I gave a [ __ ]
about for eight years of my life think
about that much intensity deployed
against one little narrow thing Ernie
Banks rated rookie 80 tops I got a wrong
oh so it's that I got it wrong because I
thought it was 80 is it 80 oh this is 83
Roberto Clemente I'm gonna be so upset
about that Ozzie Smith [ __ ] up for the
rest of the night can you go home and
create more magic can you go home and
create more magic I'm not sure right I
think we could talk about that a little
bit I think it has a lot to do with
self-awareness
I think a lot of you in this room want
to be something instead of a verse
engineer what you actually are but can
you really go home and become Sean and
and have that level of charisma and and
have that I don't know I've always felt
that talent could be honed you could
maximize by the way your kicks are
phenomenal I think you can maximize your
talent like I feel like I have a certain
amount of you know basketball talent in
my body sure I can play every day but
can i really get to that extreme level
where I could be on a basketball card
just punchline the answer's no I do not
believe that you sit here you fly into
Vegas you sit up here and listen to all
these great speakers a lot of my homies
have spoke earlier and I don't think you
go home and scale magic and so I love
Sean with all my heart but here's one
thing I can promise you you can all go
home and hustle more thank you
oh my god it's awesome chefs pokey
that's [ __ ] unbelievable
got it you're welcome
my best friend right here man that was
good that was good one did you love the
card things love them I did so well and
it is so good you like family I knew I
told them that he's gonna be pissed
about the money man yeah I forgot 80 and
83 what about that video I got yours
[ __ ] dude that video so awesome you guys
are oh we want it we want it we want it
we want it dude I love the video good
[ __ ] such good work a lot of concerts
sure
I know she's adorable how are you man
we've all got our stuff and I think that
um I think the quicker you realize yes I
may have more self-confidence than you
but you may have things that I don't I
just don't spend any time thinking what
all of you have more than me I just
focus on honing what I have more than
you 24/7 365
it's your accent it's your this it's
like it's the [ __ ] because your mom
told you you weren't good enough but
there's so many things like hey what's
your alternative
like like I just think that people are
scared to fail in front of other people
my friends I'm telling you something
right now I'm desperately excited to
fail in front of you because I don't
really give a [ __ ] what you think and B
I'm gonna learn from it and see battle
scars are attractive
I think what's holding you back is what
you think other people are gonna say
about it right if you like that problems
thanks man
it's just like like like if you want to
be an unscathed and entrepreneur and be
undefeated you're not gonna be that
great entrepreneurship is like UFC
everybody loses I'm this second you wrap
your head around that you have
dramatically higher potential because
then you will push itself further
because you're not gonna be scared to
fail and the people that are scared to
fail stay within a comfort zone and can
only hit a certain level when I started
vaynermedia do you know what everybody
said on that as an Avenue Twitter boys
starting agency hahaha that didn't scare
me that made me want to rip their
[ __ ] hearts out of their body
and if I failed then they were right
where's that lovely gal who said like
I'm gonna win right like you know I'm
like show me like I hear you but until
you do you have it I think you're just
worrying about family in front of
somebody beside yourself because you got
a piss far so it means an arts most of
you are not scared to fail for yourself
you're scared to fail and then somebody
else that you care about is judging you
I just don't give a [ __ ] but my parents
or wife or kids think yeah and that's
and it's an important thing of course I
care what they think but not more than
what I think about myself and if you're
lucky enough to make that tweak [ __ ]
just opens up guys this was a lot of fun
like I'm literally like trying to milk
it for another second and I think I'm
gonna miss a super important [ __ ]
flight so I think your actions always
speak louder than your words so I really
appreciate the love this was super fun I
need to figure out how to do this for
like eighty seven straight hours one day
and I love you guys Karen thank you
interesting day San Francisco speech
but your business calls mmm actually
documental out of that today then where
we go here
biggest a lot of videos we will show one
word from all those videos that recorded
that could be fun at it now
now Vegas to LA got some morning
meetings real hustle day two flights
back and forth to talks a bunch of
business later media stuff in between
lots of phone calls running a business
through this phone good day well good
should be bit upset you best between the
while I'm up picking used to react a
sleep
I feel you with me baby
IV with me